[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to let's
talk about an anime a film that shows
what goes on inside of you a movie that
shows that the tiny things that happen
on the outside are actually big things
on the inside the colorful strange
comedic adventure simply known as inside
out sure we've seen this idea dabbled
with an unforgettable shows and shows
we'd like to forget but this is the
first one to do it in such a clever and
unique way no other films show the
inside workings of the human bodies so
cleverly and distinctly original and
we're gonna talk about how great it is
here today all right troupe he loves the
movie but he said it was like Herman's
head oh please no one even remembers
that I missed the other whitewall
besides even if this idea has been done
before
no pinheads haven't done it in the way
that we've done it before oh yeah
nobody's ever done it like this before
what emotion are you pissed off that's
what I am hey that's my job buddy yep
a job you are stole from me osmosis
jones oh great another with chaski
fanboys
Joe what a joke osmosis joke wait you're
saying we ripped you off if the body
related pun fits hey we're gonna the
most brilliantly written films of all
time and you you're just a Farley
Brothers movie yeah that's right
you're about the people that make Jim
carrot a male cougar hey why don't we
let the critic decide by having him
review the movie instead whatever we do
we better do it fast
the critics just been sitting there
brain dead for a few minutes oh that's
why we're gonna review osmosis jones why
am I suddenly in a bad mood
[Music]
in 2001 the Farley brothers who you know
for three good movies and several waving
apologies were attached to an anime a
film about the inner workings of the
human body as well as some animation
directors obviously as well it was
colorful creative and usually forgot to
be funny
like most Farley Brothers films it
doesn't know if it wants to be a
legitimately clever adult film or a
giggle fest for two year old because
they acknowledge that farts exist
farts exist strangely enough though
everyone does end up somehow remembering
this and even years later there's still
been quite a few people who have
requested me to review this for a long
time
is it worth of requests well let's take
a look with osmosis jones the prequel
the inside out the film takes place in
oh being a Farley Brothers movie I'm
just gonna assume this New England ish
side of the US yep as we all go with
Bill Murray scratching his ass glad to
see you're aiming high there Farley's in
the old days he would have scratched his
taint Murray plays Frank a zookeeper
with a daughter who acts a lot more like
his mother because yeah again let me
just take a guess here your mother god
bless her soul you know should we just
line up all the mothers and animated
films to the electric chair is there
just a cinematic courtroom somewhere
where they're just like what are you
charged with giving the birth of life
but a monkey steals his egg which means
for some reason now he has to choke it
what can I even say to this right now
Bill Murray is choking slash possibly
dry humping a monkey I never thought I'd
have to repeat this from my plan of the
apes review but don't do it why is this
such a common theme around here as if
looking at the outside of it wasn't bad
enough we then venture inward to see
that the inside of his body is covered
in black lines for some reason this is
where we need us Moses Jones voiced by
Chris Rock we go again
yes beetlejuice cartoon we found
everything except your nose but we're
sure it'll show up in another awkward
drawing Joe this is a white blood cell
Cobb who helps to keep the inside of
Frank healthy and of course make a lot
of funds while doing so spit creek
without a path we let go peanut butter
and cellulite sandwich paint your mess
on the wrong side of the digestive tract
that's a lot of pudding they try to stop
some gingivitis which somehow ends up
affecting Frank's leg while he's eating
some fried chicken fried chicken I hear
they do great steak but something else
that seems that snuck in thorax a
disease played by Laurence Fishburne
yeah and contagious you're gonna love my
toxic love
we big shit that's gonna fuck the shit
out of me what we see bigger things are
on the mind of the mayor played by
William Shatner I'd like to announce
were beginning construction on a third
gym so just to get things straight with
Shatner in charge Frank has turned into
a fat balding unhealthy egotistical pain
in the ass and you put this guy in
anything in the juice just like
themselves honey
[Music]
you know I think they had the idea to
follow Bill Murray around with a camera
to see if he did anything funny and when
he did they just said make it a cartoon
I'm making you an appointment to see the
doctor but the mayor can't risk him
getting sick so he uses his manual
override Oh on second thought perhaps
I'll take a cold pill hmm why does that
sound familiar because beta Hey look
just because it is a control panel to
shift his thoughts while looking through
a circular screen of vision doesn't mean
we stole anything you know yeah right
in fact I smell a spinoff with you and
another original Disney classic I call
it kimba the white life that never went
that court where mostly I've been clear
of that one yeah let me know how that
rolls lawsuit works out whoo yeah we
might be in trouble that one so here's a
fun drinking game take a shot every
single time there's a cop movie cliche I
know what you're thinking come on it's a
cop movie of course there's gonna be
some calculus shades but let's just
write the next three minutes three
minutes let's count how many Coppola
Shea's they're off for kick out that
doesn't fit in who the angry
commissioner
oh how about cracking one liners against
authority being assigned a new partner
really saying he doesn't need a new
partner hmm it's on a hot romantic lead
whose personality is invisible right she
doesn't like him thinking independence
makes up for the fact that she's totally
forgettable
seven shots in the past three minutes
what the fuck you're as original as a
computer-generated DVD movie huh
god I hope I didn't fuck with her mind
too much are we in Gary Busey's head he
meets up with a minion version of iron
man named Rick's a literal pill played
by ty casted he'll david Hyde Pierce
I was developed at the University of
Chicago where I graduated Phi Beta Kappa
that midcal it's book oh look who told
them obviously don't get along
the mayor's assistant Leah played by
Brandi because clearly she'll bring a
lot to the role gives Jones the chance
to prove himself and tricks to make
Frank feel better never way tamper-proof
seal is there for your protection all
right everyone
but Jones comes across somebody who saw
a faxes work Chris Tucker's in this
movie exact Siddhant freezes him though
not allowing Jones to figure out what he
was talking about of course what he is
talking about is threats who's
apparently trying to take over his
infectious competition we run the
rackets around here take your little
hustle someplace else
well baby this ain't about no hustle
this is about the baddest illness any of
y'all have ever seen okay this is always
something that's bother me how come when
you change the color of blood it
suddenly doesn't make it gory why is
this a hard-r but if you suddenly change
the color oh it's a jello birthday party
Friday the 13th would be a G movie if
the blood have fuckin polka dots on it
what kind of sickness do you have in
mind
deadly
Wow that's a constant reminder of how
much the live-action scenes don't
connect psychotic killer gory murder
girl running around in the zoo come on
they go hand in hand like peanut butter
on that fucking scene we saw earlier
yeah I don't have a comparison just what
the hell Trix accidentally breaks up a
piece of the frozen witness so he hides
it by sticking it in his mouth just put
it in the back seat there but then again
that might not have built up to our
other crows a joke hmm let's see what do
we have in the appendix of what makes
idiots laugh snot looks good what's that
over there it's funny because you're
stupid
[Music]
so flex blows up the dam getting all the
snot out but really for no good reason
drinks decides he still wants to partner
up with Jones why don't we find you
another more capable officer to work
with sir if it's all the same to you and
because the piano music is singling me
to do so I think I'll stay with Jones
Souter Smith Jones reveals what a shock
he has a tragic backstory you see a
while ago he was supposed to keep Frank
well during his daughter's science fair
hell Frank was actually kind of us to
end up guy more than her teacher anyway
played by Molly Shannon your daughter
Shane I am just absolutely crazy about
her well if you mean that I'm gonna keep
her to be fair this is the only laugh
Murray has gotten in the film so far
okay oh yeah that Zach's project
he's a little slow the doctor says that
he has a brain like a tangerine
mm-hmm so remember kids if a slow kid is
having trouble at your school this
family film says it's okay to make fun
of it just be sure the Farley brothers
are around to film it when you do what
we're gonna get him in a anyway God what
the fuck was this write it again
Frank right Adrian kids oysters which
resulted in him puking all over the
teacher and Jesus Christ give that
photographer an award he must have known
the fucking millisecond it was going to
come out to shoot something so perfectly
composed
he even got fired from his job at the
peace effect oh come on the real Bill
Murray's done that at tons of party
she's never gotten kicked off the scent
this I guess is the excuse why his life
is such a wreck now though really it's a
pretty lame excuse how did he go from a
pea soup factory to a zoo cleaning job
they have nothing in common and why is
he a bum loser now the rule isn't one
big school cafeteria I think he can
bounce back okay but hey then we
wouldn't have classic Farley comedy like
this what's wrong now
oh it's this damnit oh do me a favor huh
don't you get old listen to the toe
don't you get oh Jesus I wish pirate
Palpatine back there we use this force
powers to end this scene you want to
shut the fuck up you want to order some
of my delicious shrimp with tartar sauce
but Rick's and Joan's aren't done
looking for answers on the plus side at
least we know none of the punky get
quite as bad as back into this fat beef
base bushes do my back seat
Oh your movie was so stupid and
overloaded his brain with PTSD both
movements know that we have to show him
something even more painful and you got
what
[Music]
whoo-hoo wait what's that our bad huh
unless it was a charity ad in which case
his reason they email
anyway after blown into blow Jones
sneaks in and discovers the disease is
planning to kill off Frank but sadly he
also lets him get away can you guess
what's gonna follow now disregarding
orders destruction of public flesh
popping a pimple without a permit what
the heck are you doing up there
your painful buddy cop movie tropes sir
why Thank You Carson hmm I think I'll
start to eat the cop getting fired
cliche the fire followed by the nobody
believes him when he's telling the truth
cliche without Jones Frank could have
been in mortal danger you'd love to
prove that wouldn't you mr. Dixon and
for dessert
how about the finding out something that
was important it turns out was all like
Lachey you're nothing but I want to be a
placebo over-the-counter useless funny
or not funny not funny
any variation no variations whatsoever
very good Thank You counsel
Garcon means boy well somebody's on the
first five minutes of Pulp Fiction of
course the big question in all of this
is if drinks was a placebo the whole
time how did he physically stop all the
symptoms wouldn't it be more clever if
you use like a psychological approach
like talking the symptoms out of
continuing to affect that way he'd be
much more of an opposite to Chris Rock's
character as well
we're not bit more funny and made more
sense well as you quickly notice
psychological intelligence is not this
film strong point take for example this
II maybe if you and Mom took better care
of yourselves
your mom died because she got sick Wow
I mean bill I love you I think you were
robbed at the Oscars by Sean Penn but
that wasn't acting wasteland that you
just gave us I mean we can scan to see
if there's any emotion there I mean any
no whatsoever who talks to their kid
about their dead wife while eating a
fucking Chino it was that in the script
was the cheeto essential to the
heartbreaking moment that the music
suggests were supposed to have with Lion
King work as well as simple as much and
got snacks the whole time
[Music]
so what what partner gives up on himself
resulting in our hero walking around
moping just before he gives the pep talk
to get his partner back like they're
shooting out these cliches faster than I
can sail he goes to watch some dreams
which in this world is similar to movies
wait a minute that's I don't know guys
he's got a point on that one
they haven't UNPO stirs and everything
well maybe we just put it in our
subconscious which we represent by the
way as a dark gray scarier boost Oh give
me that subconsciousness represented
that's a mess can I say that curse word
now Leah discovers Thrax plan to kill
Frank and yeah is her dress shrinking or
just afraid the floor because that's her
ass
no but that's her ass there is no way
those lines could be mistaken for
anything else
I don't know who are the animation staff
wants to fuck a blood cell but even
horny women from clubs are looking at
that like Carol you're wearing a strip
of purple scotch tape right now oh wait
that's the always stay up a quality
Chris Elliott he plays Frank's brother
who is unaware that the virus is quickly
claiming Frank's wife Jessica's only 108
degrees or phrase thought is enough I
wish I was an orphan is the bus really
the best place to do that let me just
put that on your hero it'd look good at
Senator Palpatine just that Frank starts
to get worse his daughter sees him in
front of the bus and gets up calling 911
this movie is killing him give me 50
cc's of lost in translation stat oh
sorry Mike it was a prostitute from
years ago you can understand the
confusion though enjoy the funeral we
talked briefly twice so I feel I've
earned this big a shot into his
daughter's eye where they have the final
bet when I take down Frank's pretty
little girl
going down she's not going down you're
going down on her I probably should
rephrase that but honestly it's not fast
anything else said in this movie she
eyelash falls off killing the disease
Jones returns with the cure and dr. Ben
Affleck seems to have brought Frank back
to life oh wait can I try that emotional
moment again I clearly should have been
eating a pork rind or something so the
day is saved Jones and drinks are back
on the force and Frank goes on a
beautiful hike with his daughter what's
the most heartwarming way to end this
old Oh
Bart how was the old they were the new
well at the very least you can say this
film represented a turd very well the
same thing is there are some clever
ideas in this moment I mean the designs
are great the environment itself is
pretty cool and sometimes even some of
the pubs are kind of clever
the animation as well is so gorgeous to
look at it's just so colorful and
flowing but the story is every boring
buddy cop flick the live-action stuff is
awkwardly done and a lot of the humor
just isn't that funny
I admire this film a lot more for its
creativity but in terms of a good comedy
or action film they both fall pretty but
who knows maybe somebody saw these
creative choices and was inspired by it
years later
yeah inspire to rip it off okay clearly
we stole some things from you thank you
some of those things couldn't have been
just a coincidence thank you but we did
something with them something smart
something meaningful something that can
change and help lies all your will we
did was help people lose their faith in
David hi pears
hey don't force me to make my voice even
more gravelly and choking my god how do
you mean a living off that voice it's
kind of like nuclear power if yous right
it's effective but use it the wrong way
and it will fuck you up for life it's
also far away from the control panel
what does that have to do with fuck what
are you looking at balled out like a vet
Oh God in early 2000s movie Chris Rock
hey Timmy up with Anthony Hopkins again
and we can do anything even when we
don't want to admit it
I know what you're thinking how can I
get all these people I just saw on a
t-shirt well now you can
the Statue Creek t-shirts are back and
in any color that you want but they'd
isn't just in mr. Craig guess all your
other favorite characters the devil
hyper fangirl Santa Christ and yes
there's even more on the way you asked
for important under peer pressure like
pure bitches get nostalgia critic
t-shirts now at the link below they're
unlike anything you've ever put on your
body unless you wear shirts by him
anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]